hey there I've got something that I'd
like to tell you about I'm very excited
about it and it is this design banjo
philosopher which is available in the
philosoph that's my store that you see
on my YouTube videos and in other places
where you can find Sadler oriented merch
for those who've been asking for it and
for the time being there is a special
offer you can get 25 off on this
particular design through spring you can
see the coupon code below you can just
click see more or video description and
it will have it in there for you and I'd
like to tell you a little bit about this
because it's kind of meaningful for me
so some of you may or may not know that
years and years ago I brought my banjo
into my intro to philosophy class to
help illustrate Aristotle's metaphysics
and the notion of the four causes I
recorded that particular session a lot
of people have commented about it and
when I first started thinking about you
know what should I offer for Merch I
thought about that episode and I kind of
like doing this you know
primary colors plus green design with me
holding the banjo in various stances
that's a much younger me that you see
there and so I put it together and then
I didn't really think much of it until
lately when people started you know
asking about it and suggesting it and
even my kids started saying hey what's
that banjo philosopher banjo metaphysics
thing that you've got going on so this
is it this is the design if you want to
show your appreciation your support
whatever else it is that you want to
show you might uh check it out and get
yourself a shirt like the one that I
have here and you can also check out the
video where I lead my class through
Aristotle's four causes and I get the
banjo out and even play it a little bit
for them so that's the whole pitch
that's everything that I need to say
here maybe you find it interesting thing
there's all sorts of other cool stuff in
the philosoph as well I'm going to be
having more designs coming out but this
is the one that I'm excited about right
now and they sent it to me and I think
it came out looking pretty good so if
you want something that's gonna make
people say
what the hell is that that you're
wearing maybe this is your speed so I'll
sign off here and leave it up to you to
decide whether you want to get yourself
some Gregory B Sadler merch and
specifically banjo metaphysics or banjo
philosopher